Diese Untertitel
sind live produziert.
sub1
Der G20-Gipfel der Industriestaaten -
sub2
virtuell und beherrscht
von einer Frage:
sub3
Wie kann die Welt
die Corona-Krise überwinden?
sub4
Ein neues Grundsatzprogramm
und ein klares Ziel:
sub5
Grünen-Chef Habeck sieht seine Partei
auf dem Weg ins Kanzleramt.
sub6
Klimaforscher im Weltraum:
Der Radarsatellit Sentinel-6
sub7
soll den Anstieg des Meeresspiegels
im Blick halten,
sub8
präzise wie nie zuvor.
sub9
Guten Abend, schön,
dass Sie dabei sind,
sub10
wie auch Norbert König für den Sport.
sub11
Wir beginnen mit einer Videoschalte
der mächtigsten Staats-
sub12
und Regierungschefs der Welt -
dem G20-Gipfel.
sub13
Ein spannendes Treffen, nicht nur,
sub14
weil US-Präsident Trump nun
überraschend doch teilnimmt.
sub15
Die G20: Das ist die Gruppe
der großen Wirtschaftsmächte,
sub16
also der Europäischen Union
und 19 Ländern.
sub17
Hier leben zwei Drittel
aller Menschen weltweit.
sub18
Beim Gipfel geht es zwei Tage
um zwei große Herausforderungen:
sub19
die Corona-Pandemie
und die Klimakrise.
sub20
Und dann ist da noch ein brisantes
Thema abseits der Tagesordnung:
sub21
Menschenrechte im Gastgeberland
Saudi-Arabien.
sub22
Anne Gellinek.
sub23
Ein einsamer Reiter
trägt die Fahne des G20-Clubs
sub24
durch die saudische Wüste.
sub25
Kampfflugzeuge steigen
über Riad in die Luft.
sub26
Saudi-Arabien wäre gern stolzer
Gastgeber des G20-Clubs gewesen.
sub27
Wegen der Corona-Krise aber
sub28
ist der Gipfel zu einer
Videokonferenz geschrumpft.
sub29
Europäischen Teilnehmern
bleibt damit die heikle Begegnung
sub30
mit dem saudischen König
und dem Kronprinzen erspart,
sub31
die wegen zahlreicher
Menschenrechtsverletzungen
sub32
in der Kritik stehen.
sub33
In der Eröffnungsrede ruft der fast
85-jährige König Salman dazu auf,
sub34
die Pandemie und ihre Folgen
gemeinsam zu bekämpfen.
sub35
Unsere Bürger und Volkswirtschaften
stehen noch immer unter Schock.
sub36
Wir werden unser Bestes tun,
sub37
die Krise durch internationale
Zusammenarbeit zu bewältigen.
sub38
Donald Trump hatte die G20-Treffen
der letzten Jahre lahmgelegt.
sub39
Der inzwischen abgewählte US-Präsi-
dent nimmt zwar am Nachmittag teil,
sub40
beschwert sich aber
parallel per Twitter
sub41
über angeblichen Wahlbetrug
im US-Staat Georgia.
sub42
Die Europäer haben längst seinem
Nachfolger Joe Biden gratuliert
sub43
und freuen sich unverhohlen auf
einen Neustart der Zusammenarbeit
sub44
im Kampf gegen Corona.
sub45
Die Vereinigten Staaten haben sich
bei diesem Thema bislang verweigert.
sub46
Aber ich hoffe,
sub47
dass das unter dem neu gewählten
Präsidenten anders wird.
sub48
Trump bleibt sich unterdessen treu
sub49
und verspricht,
zuerst alle Amerikaner zu impfen.
sub50
Saudis, Chinesen und Europäer
werben dagegen für mehr Geld
sub51
für eine internationale Initiative,
die dafür sorgen soll,
sub52
dass auch ärmere Länder
Zugang zu Impfstoffen bekommen.
sub53
Während Donald Trump
die letzten G20-Gipfel
sub54
durch Blockade beherrschte, ist
er jetzt nur noch eine Randnotiz.
sub55
Die Europäer hoffen,
dass die neue US-Regierung
sub56
als vollwertiges Mitglied
in den G20-Club zurückkehrt
sub57
und mitmacht beim Kampf
gegen Corona und den Klimawandel.
sub58
Zu den Corona-Zahlen:
sub59
Die halten sich in Deutschland
weiter auf hohem Niveau.
sub60
Laut Robert Koch-Institut
sub61
gab es binnen 24 Stunden
22.964 Neuinfektionen.
sub62
Im Vergleich zum Samstag der
vergangenen Woche sind das 503 mehr.
sub63
Die Zahl der Todesfälle im Zusammen-
hang mit dem Virus stieg um 254.
sub64
Und jetzt nach Leipzig,
sub65
wo vor zwei Wochen
eine "Querdenker"-Demo
sub66
für Ärger und dann zu politischen
Debatten geführt hatte.
sub67
Kaum einer der 20.000 Demonstranten
sub68
hatte sich an die
Maskenpflicht gehalten.
sub69
Auch heute versammelten sich wieder
sub70
Gegner der Corona-Maßnahmen
in der Stadt.
sub71
Gleichzeitig beteiligten sich
auch viele an Gegenprotesten.
sub72
Über den Tag in Leipzig:
Stefan Kelch.
sub73
Die Bürger-Initiative
"Leipzig nimmt Platz"
sub74
will sich
den Augustusplatz zurückerobern,
sub75
das Symbol für
den friedlichen Protest von 1989.
sub76
Der war vor zwei Wochen
von einer Großdemo
sub77
gegen die Corona-Maßnahmen
mit Bezug auf '89 besetzt worden.
sub78
Für Bürgerrechtlerinnen
wie Gesine Oltmanns
sub79
ist das schwer erträglich.
sub80
Das hat viele unheimlich
betroffen gemacht und auch wütend,
sub81
dass dieser Ring, der für uns
ein Symbol für einen Aufbruch
sub82
in Demokratie und
Rechtsstaatlichkeit ist,
sub83
so gebraucht worden ist.
sub84
Polizei und Ordnungskräfte
sorgen diesmal konsequent dafür,
sub85
dass die Corona-Verordnung
eingehalten wird.
sub86
Null Toleranz hat sie angekündigt.
sub87
Das muss auch der Anmelder
sub88
einer Demo von Kritikern
der Corona-Maßnahmen erfahren:
sub89
Der will keine Maske tragen.
sub90
Aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
kann ich keine tragen.
sub91
Nicht umsonst habe ich ein Attest.
sub92
Doch dieses Attest stellt sich
als unzureichend heraus.
sub93
Die Versammlung wird beendet,
noch bevor sie angefangen hat.
sub94
Seine etwa 500 Anhänger müssen
den Versammlungsort verlassen.
sub95
Zur Stunde sind viele Teilnehmer
der verschiedensten Versammlungen
sub96
in der Stadt unterwegs.
sub97
Vereinzelt berichtet die Polizei
auch von Zusammenstößen.
sub98
Der Kampf gegen die Pandemie:
sub99
In der Türkei ist er
für die Regierung
sub100
eine besondere Gratwanderung.
sub101
Denn obwohl die angeschlagene Lira
sich zuletzt einigermaßen erholt hat,
sub102
bleibt die Wirtschaftslage
angespannt.
sub103
Die zweite Infektionswelle zwingt
das Land trotzdem zu Maßnahmen:
sub104
Seit gestern sind die Restaurants
und Cafes wieder dicht.
sub105
Und es gilt erneut
eine Ausgangssperre,
sub106
von abends acht bis morgens um zehn.
sub107
Jörg Brase.
sub108
Die Straßen sind leer,
Ausgangssperre im ganzen Land -
sub109
doch erstmal nur für Samstagnacht.
sub110
Bis gestern Abend durften
Restaurants noch öffnen.
sub111
Auch damit, so hatte es
der Präsident verkündet,
sub112
ist ab diesem Wochenende Schluss.
sub113
Die Restaurants und Cafes werden
Essen nur noch ausliefern.
sub114
Alle Sportwettkämpfe werden
ohne Zuschauer ausgetragen.
sub115
Die Teehäuser werden
bis auf weiteres geschlossen.
sub116
Seit Wochen schon
dürfen Ältere und Junge
sub117
nur stundenweise auf die Straße.
sub118
Im Freien darf nicht mehr
geraucht werden.
sub119
Es gilt ein Regelwirrwarr,
über das sich einige
sub120
in den sozialen Netzwerken
lustig machen,
sub121
viele andere aber sind verunsichert.
sub122
Die neuen Maßnahmen
reichen nicht aus.
sub123
Sie sehen doch, wie voll es
hier ist, das wird nicht reichen.
sub124
Ich glaube nicht
an die veröffentlichten Zahlen.
sub125
Wir bräuchten einen kompletten
Shutdown für mindestens drei Wochen.
sub126
Die Regierung verspricht,
sub127
dass ein Impfstoff
schon bald zur Verfügung stehe.
sub128
Gesundheitsexperten warnen,
dass die Zeit drängt.
sub129
Wenn wir in zwei Wochen
noch immer dort stehen,
sub130
wo wir jetzt
mit den Maßnahmen angefangen haben,
sub131
und wenn die Zahl der Schwerkranken
weiter zunimmt
sub132
und wir an die Grenzen
des Gesundheitssystems stoßen,
sub133
dann müssen härtere Maßnahmen
getroffen werden.
sub134
Vorerst aber bleibt die Regierung
sub135
bei den nur nächtlichen
Ausgangssperren.
sub136
Aus Angst vor größerem Schaden
für die türkische Wirtschaft.
sub137
Und wie die Corona-Lage
in Deutschlands Nachbarländern ist,
sub138
sehen Sie in unserer ZDFheute-App.
sub139
Ein interaktiver Überblick
zu Infektionszahlen,
sub140
aktuellen Maßnahmen und vielem mehr.
sub141
Corona zwingt auch die Grünen dazu,
ihren Parteitag virtuell abzuhalten.
sub142
In Umfragen liegen sie aktuell
bei 20 % und streben
sub143
entsprechend selbstbewusst
ins Kanzleramt.
sub144
Jetzt brauchen sie noch
ein neues Grundsatzprogramm,
sub145
das möglichst viele mitnimmt
und wenige verprellt.
sub146
Aus Berlin Andreas Huppert
und Lars Bohnsack.
sub147
Alles ist anders dieses Mal:
sub148
tägliche Corona-Schnelltests für
Vorstand, Mitarbeiter und Presse.
sub149
Die Delegierten aber
sind nur online dabei.
sub150
Nicht alles
funktioniert reibungslos:
sub151
Leider hören wir dich noch nicht.
sub152
Jetzt ist wieder das Problem,
Philipp,
sub153
wir sehen dich zwar,
aber hören dich nicht.
sub154
Parteitag digital:
sub155
Die Grünen geben sich
ein neues Grundsatzprogramm
sub156
und formulieren dabei ganz klar
ihren Machtanspruch.
sub157
Sie wollen ins Kanzleramt.
sub158
Wenn es stimmt, dass eine neue Zeit
neue Antworten erfordert,
sub159
dass eine neue Zeit einen neuen Ton,
eine Farbe der Hoffnung braucht,
sub160
dann stellen wir uns
diesem Anspruch.
sub161
Doch der Weg zur Macht
erfordert Kompromisse.
sub162
Auch solche, die ans
Grundsätzliche der Partei gehen
sub163
und die nicht jeder mittragen will.
sub164
Beispiel Klimaschutz:
sub165
Die letzten Monate waren hart.
sub166
Trotzdem müssen wir
für Paris weiterhin kämpfen.
sub167
Vielleicht ist jetzt gerade
oder heute genau der Zeitpunkt,
sub168
wo Ihr euch einmal fragen könnt,
sub169
warum Ihr mal mit uns
auf den Straßen gestanden habt.
sub170
Experimente können wir uns
nicht mehr leisten.
sub171
Dazu ist es zu spät.
sub172
Erst auf Druck von Basis
und Umweltaktivisten
sub173
werden die Klimaziele verschärft.
sub174
Wir haben gemeinsam unseren Text
sub175
noch einmal besser und deutlicher
gemacht, auch mit der Perspektive,
sub176
dass in den nächsten zehn Jahren
was passieren muss.
sub177
Deswegen geht von dieser Stelle nun
eine neue, zusätzliche Kraft aus.
sub178
Die Grünen wollen regieren,
auch im Bund.
sub179
Dieses Selbstbewusstsein zeigt sich
auch im neuen Grundsatzprogramm.
sub180
Ralph Schumacher in Berlin: In
welchem Dilemma stecken die Grünen?
sub181
Der Machtanspruch der Parteispitze
sub182
sorgt an der Basis
für Bauchschmerzen.
sub183
Das Kanzleramt erfordert
Kompromisse.
sub184
Das neue Grundsatzprogramm markiert
einen Fortschritt.
sub185
Klimaaktivisten erfordern
Entschlossenheit im Kampf
sub186
gegen den Klimawandel.
sub187
Es bleibt ein schwieriger Spagat
für die Grünen.
sub188
Und es droht Konkurrenz.
sub189
Die SPD hat ihren Kanzlerkandidaten,
die Union ringt um den ihren.
sub190
Aber die Grünen wollen da partout
noch nicht drüber reden, oder?
sub191
Aus Sicht der Partei ist das
ein Luxusproblem.
sub192
Der Druck wächst.
sub193
Geht es nach den Grünen,
sub194
soll die Entscheidung
erst nach Ostern fallen.
sub195
Nach den Störaktionen von Gästen
der AfD-Fraktion im Bundestag
sub196
hält Thüringens Innenminister
Georg Maier, SPD,
sub197
ein Verbot der AfD für denkbar.
sub198
Wenn eine Partei sich immer weiter
radikalisiere,
sub199
steht am Ende die Möglichkeit
eines Parteienverbots,
sub200
sagte Maier gegenüber dem ZDF.
sub201
Die AfD versuche, die Demokratie
von innen heraus anzugreifen.
sub202
Thüringens heute wiedergewählter
AfD-Chef Björn Höcke
sub203
nannte Maiers Äußerung,
so wörtlich, "dämlich".
sub204
Eine verbindliche Frauenquote
für Vorstände großer Unternehmen -
sub205
darauf hatte sich
die Große Koalition gestern geeinigt.
sub206
Der Präsident des Deutschen Instituts
für Wirtschaftsforschung, Fratzscher,
sub207
sieht darin hohe Signalwirkung für
Gleichstellung und Chancengleichheit.
sub208
Politikerinnen von Grünen
und Linken kritisieren,
sub209
der Schritt sei zu klein.
sub210
Im afghanischen Kabul
wurden bei einem Anschlag
sub211
mindestens acht Menschen getötet,
mehr als 30 wurden verletzt.
sub212
Zahlreiche Mörsergranaten
schlugen in Wohngebieten ein.
sub213
Auch im Botschaftsviertel
gab es Explosionen.
sub214
Trotz Friedensgesprächen
zwischen Regierung
sub215
und radikal-islamischen Taliban
sub216
gibt es immer wieder Anschläge
in Afghanistan.
sub217
Einige reklamiert die Terrormiliz
"Islamischer Staat" für sich.
sub218
In Brasilien haben
in mehreren Städten
sub219
Hunderte gegen Rassismus
demonstriert,
sub220
nach dem gewaltsamen Tod
eines Schwarzen.
sub221
Sie trugen Transparente mit der
Aufschrift "Schwarze Leben zählen".
sub222
Am Donnerstagabend hatten
Sicherheitskräfte eines Supermarktes
sub223
den 40-Jährigen zu Tode geprügelt.
sub224
Filialen der Supermarktkette
sub225
wurden von Demonstrierenden
gestürmt und verwüstet.
sub226
Vor allem für Küstenbewohner
ist es eine Bedrohung:
sub227
der stetig steigende Meeresspiegel.
sub228
Vor einer Stunde
startete ein Satellit,
sub229
der diese Entwicklung
besser im Blick hat denn je.
sub230
Sentinel-6, hier in Originalgröße,
ist ein hochmoderner Satellit
sub231
des europäischen
Erdbeobachtungsprogramms Copernikus.
sub232
Mit an Bord: ein extrem
leistungsstarkes Radar.
sub233
Es kann aus einer Höhe
von etwa 1.300 km
sub234
die Meeresoberfläche vermessen
sub235
und so früher
vor Überflutungen warnen.
sub236
Inken Klinge.
sub237
Pünktlich um 18.17 Uhr ist
in Kalifornien erstmals
sub238
eine SpaceX-Rakete mit einem
ESA-Satelliten an Bord gestartet.
sub239
Sentinel-6 soll mit
einem neuen Radar Daten liefern,
sub240
mit denen die Höhe des Meeres milli-
metergenau bestimmt werden kann.
sub241
Der Satellit sendet
Radarimpulse aus und fängt sie,
sub242
reflektiert vom Wasser, wieder auf.
sub243
Wichtig bei Meereshöhenbestimmung
ist, dass man das
sub244
nicht ein Mal macht, sondern
über einen sehr langen Zeitraum,
sub245
denn nur dann
sieht man diese Effekte.
sub246
Seit knapp 30 Jahren
liefern Satelliten
sub247
bereits Daten über den Ozean.
sub248
In dieser Zeit ist der Meeresspiegel
um etwa 9 cm angestiegen.
sub249
Sentinel-6 wird zunächst
mit seinem Vorgänger Jason-3
sub250
als Tandem unterwegs sein,
bis er ihn vollständig ablöst.
sub251
Die Daten über den Anstieg der Meere
werden dann hier bearbeitet,
sub252
bei EUMETSAT in Darmstadt,
sub253
zuständig für meteorologische
Satelliten in Europa.
sub254
Dieser Anstieg scheint sich
zu beschleunigen.
sub255
Das werden wir mit Sentinel-6
nachweisen können.
sub256
Dieser Anstieg ist
eine Temperaturerhöhung
sub257
und es ist auch mehr Wasser
in den Ozeanen,
sub258
also der gesamte Wasserhaushalt
spiegelt sich da wider.
sub259
Die Mission Sentinel-6
sub260
ist ein gemeinschaftliches Projekt
von ESA und NASA.
sub261
Verschiedene Berechnungen gehen
von einem Anstieg des Meeresspiegels
sub262
von rund einem Meter
bis zum Ende des Jahrhunderts aus.
sub263
Im Sport wird auch geflogen:
Die Skispringer sind wieder los.
sub264
Mit einem Platz auf dem Treppchen
für das deutsche Quartett.
sub265
Die Form stimmt schon bei Weltmeister
Markus Eisenbichler
sub266
und seinen Kollegen.
sub267
Im Mannschaftswettbewerb
von Wisla in Polen
sub268
mussten sie sich nur dem Team
aus Österreich geschlagen geben.
sub269
Ein kleiner Gleichgewichtsfehler
kostete den Sieg.
sub270
Markus Eisenbichler sicherte
mit dieser risikoreichen Landung
sub271
bei 127 m aber Platz 2
für das deutsche Team
sub272
mit Constantin Schmid,
Pius Paschke und Karl Geiger.
sub273
Am Ende war es sehr knapp, wir sind
nicht fehlerfrei geblieben leider,
sub274
aber für den ersten Wettkampf
sehr gut.
sub275
Eine knappe Niederlage
gegen Österreich.
sub276
Schlussspringer Stefan Kraft
mit einem technisch sauberen Sprung
sub277
auf 127 m, beeindruckte nicht nur
die drittplatzierten Polen.
sub278
Der erste Saisonsieg
vor Deutschland,
sub279
das aber mit Markus Eisenbichler
sub280
morgen im Einzel
auch einen Sieganwärter hat.
sub281
Marijama Jamanka
und Francesco Friedrich
sub282
haben ihre Zweierbobs
zum Sieg gesteuert,
sub283
beim Weltcup-Auftakt
in Sigulda in Lettland.
sub284
Der elfmalige Weltmeister Friedrich
sub285
verdrängte mit seinem Anschieber
Thorsten Margis
sub286
durch einen starken zweiten Lauf
sub287
seinen Teamkollegen Johannes Lochner
noch auf Platz 2.
sub288
Olympiasiegerin Jamanka fuhr mit
ihrer neuen Anschieberin Vanessa Mark
sub289
bei deren Weltcup-Debüt zum Sieg,
sub290
dreizehn Hundertstel
vor dem Team Österreich.
sub291
Kleiner Rückschlag für Hansi Flick
sub292
in seinem 50. Pflichtspiel
als Cheftrainer von Bayern München:
sub293
Es reicht nur zum Unentschieden
sub294
in der Bundesliga-Partie
gegen Werder Bremen.
sub295
Kingsley Coman verhinderte immerhin
sub296
mit seinem Treffer zum 1:1 die
erste Heimniederlage seit einem Jahr.
sub297
Das aktuelle sportstudio
mit zwei Abendspielen
sub298
wie gewohnt um 23 Uhr.
sub299
Morgen gibt's Dreistreifen-Wetter,
sagt Gunther Tiersch - heißt:
sub300
Sonne an den Küsten,
trüb in der Mitte und Sonne im Süden.
sub301
Mehr dazu gleich.
sub302
Um 22.45 Uhr freut sich Christian
Sievers auf Sie im heute journal.
sub303
Wir freuen uns, wenn Sie morgen
wieder dabei sind.
sub304
Machen Sie sich einen schönen
Samstagabend, auf Wiedersehen.
sub305
Im Norden wird es noch nasser.
sub306
Für uns alle wird es morgen
etwas milder werden.
sub307
Die Luft kommt aus Westen,
da ist es milder.
sub308
Sie erreicht die Ostsee,
das Baltikum, da ist es frostfrei.
sub309
Erst östlich von Moskau
gibt es Dauerfrost.
sub310
Am mildesten ist es
noch immer am Mittelmeer.
sub311
Bei uns bleibt es frostfrei
im Norden.
sub312
Dafür wird es wieder frostig
im Süden.
sub313
Bei dem klaren Himmel
bilden sich Nebelfelder.
sub314
In Norddeutschland an den Küsten
regnet es die ganze Nacht über
sub315
bei kräftigem Westwind.
sub316
Morgen nach dem Regen
kommt dort die Sonne raus.
sub317
Es wird freundlich.
sub318
Immer noch starker Wind aus Westen.
sub319
Sonst aber noch Regen
im norddeutschen Tiefland,
sub320
der nachmittags immer schwächer wird.
sub321
Auch in der Mitte ist es eher trüb.
sub322
Dann im Süden freundlicher,
meist scheint die Sonne,
sub323
mit Nebelfeldern v.a. an der Donau.
sub324
Zum Nachmittag werden die Wolken
aus dem Norden etwas dichter.
sub325
Es bleibt dort aber trocken.
sub326
Die Aussichten:
sub327
Es wird kaum noch regnen.
sub328
Dienstag, Mittwoch trockenes Wetter,
teils neblig-trüb, teils sonnig.